[Music]
they call me the coach that never punts
and we play the game of football a lot
differently you don't understand the
hate I deal with people hate us but I'm
just trying to win games I've been asked
a lot of questions about the way I think
about the game of football one of those
questions are you the beautiful mind of
football I'm definitely not the
beautiful mind of football the weird
mind of football I hope and I hate hope
because that's not a good plan I hope
that that's your mentality I know it is
for a summer he loves to play mind games
with you like a little quarterback
battle one time when he was trying to
decide who would go out first we played
Rock Paper Scissors shoot
and the guy chose dynamite and he said
well that's being creative you get to go
out there you win crazy over
enthusiastic crazy and angle me and find
if we lose next week you're gonna think
this week is a dang cakewalk I
understand that Cameron you owe us
Cameron you understand that do you even
believe it does
we're brainwashed in society and to
thinking things are the way that they've
always been and football is no different
well I would describe plastic Adam E as
unorthodox because for one they very
seldom if ever punt we've never
practiced punt returns we've never
practice plenty it's a no-brainer that
you don't put the football to me that's
just not the way the game should be
played and if you look at the analytics
nowadays they'll tell you that - we
onside kick every time until we've
gotten a substantial lead I think the
term mad scientist would be an
appropriate term for Kevin 9 deep 7 6 we
run a lot of what people would call
trick plays but we don't even call them
trick plays they're just a normal part
of our offense and our routine and
everything we do almost like backyard
football he'll even tell you he's gonna
run a trick play which is what he's done
to me before he's told me the first
place is gonna be a trick play and he's
true to the word
when I took over in 2003 our school had
never been passed the final fool that
wasn't good enough for me I went to win
state championships to do that we play
up a couple classifications in our state
and other schools have more kids to pull
for a football team from three and four
times as many so we couldn't play the
same game as them and expect to have
better results so what we did we started
using analytics and I came across a
video of a college professor where he
had analyzed three years of football
games at every level of friend thousands
of gamesters computer and based on all
the data he came up with the fact that
he thought that team shouldn't punt at
all I seen him go for it on 4th and 19
at his own five I don't care where we're
at on the field the analytics and the
numbers say go for it on fourth down
we're definitely not afraid to do that I
think a lot of it comes down to fact
you've got to be willing to roll the
dice in seven is a dice roller son of a
gun
I'm not the gambler if you're doing it
against the numbers that's when you're
the gambler that's when that's what we
are we go to the casinos we onside kick
every time unless we're up 21 points
also plays in the way that we view
possessions it is a turnover if you
don't get it you're giving it to the
other team on the 45 if you kick it into
the end zone they get it on the 20
there's a 25-yard window that you're
willing to sacrifice with a chance to
get the football we increase the total
number of possessions we're gonna score
more points there's a big debate going
on as to where the teams should go for -
or not go for - and if we are better at
making - than they are we will go for -
to get them to chase or have to do that
the numbers are simple if you can make
it fifty percent of the time or more you
go for two he's very polarizing probably
scored more points that I needed to at
the time and it's left a bitter taste in
some opponents to them house good god it
bothers me that people think that we're
running up the score due to the way we
play the game it's gonna be that way I
thought I'm not gonna let those guys
tell me how to play the game if I could
statistically prove that I'm right what
I'm doing analytics pressure the way we
use it right now this could be the
future of football you look at the read
option you look at tempo those started
in high school went up to college and
now our filter and trickling into the
pros somewhat
when hunter Henry a player here was
getting recruited I know Nick Saban's
been in here less miles Gus Malzahn Bret
Bielema he's get on the phone with Chip
Kelly I think the people that need to
implement the system the most are the
bottom level teams that are consistently
bad in the NFL and an FBS one of the
reasons the analytics of the game itself
what do they have to lose they've been
doing the same things over and over and
getting the same result why would you
not try something different I think a
lot of coaches are scared to use the
system because of job security take an
analytical approach 5-10 years ago it
was a novelty some people are beginning
to do it a couple years ago I watched
the Moneyball movie and I was very
intrigued by when people would use
numbers against traditional thinking and
the results that they got there are some
philosophies in high school football day
I believe at some point will transcender
the college ranks and maybe even
eventually the professional rank cameras
will those guys you know when you're
successfully like we hate with one thing
everybody does I've been respectful he's
done he believes he's the best coach in
the country I believe he is - this
program is built a foundation a change
from just being a normal high school
when he took over
now we're sponsored by adidas college
coaches are here all the time I coached
it Alabama if I coached for the Dallas
Cowboys
I'm gonna run this system oh I believe
that this is the right way to play the
game and if you look at the analytics
nowadays they'll tell you that too
[Applause]
[Music]